first you want to talk about super bowl
is that rigged
did they give it to la i mean there were
some rough calls at the end of that game
yo there was a bowling call was crazy
gotta be rigged right bro it was
on my conspiracy [ __ ] but now there was
a bad call earlier on a touchdown the
cincinnati caught yeah where jalen
ramsey should have he he like swiped
jaylen ramsey's face mask and caught a
pass and it was a touchdown yeah but
also jaylen ramsey got away with the
pass interference earlier jamar chase
the bengals receiver caught it anyway
[ __ ] fantastic catch but there was no
flags thrown there they were just
letting them play and then all of a
sudden in the last minute what would
have been fourth down and the rams would
have either had to go for it and
probably not converted and lost or
kicked a field goal and then tried to
win with like a minute left uh they call
it holding and then they get a first
down yeah and then they called another
[ __ ] penalty after that kind of you
know what's kind of interesting is the
uh it was holding though it was whole it
was over wait the linebacker that now
look at it from a different angle that
was very ticky tag you don't you don't
call that i'm telling you like buy the
book sure but also buy the book there's
everything everything
which defender wants to be that guy that
got beat
and loses the game he barely i'm telling
you he actually didn't even grab you
could call pass interference maybe but
he had his hand right here which
sometimes they'll call but he took it
off quickly and then swiped away yeah he
held the jersey a little bit too like it
was a small grab of the jersey i'm
telling you very right now but you don't
call it let's just say there was a small
grab but it was i mean that's a really
egregious call especially for that party
if you didn't call it nobody would have
said anything yeah especially the way
they let them play all games that's true
so it was different from the rest of the
game yes i'll give you that interesting
thing
that came out i guess maybe last night
but definitely today the last play of
the game where burro gets pretty much
sacked by tom and byron yeah i think he
got the pass off but whatever it doesn't
matter um
if you look down field
jamar chase
had just dropped jalen ramsey
and was free yeah
touchdown
nobody close
there's a picture of jayla ramsey
stumbling on the ground
aaron donald saved that season and this
is why i said i think the rams win
because if you cannot if you can get to
the other team's quarterback you're
probably gonna win no quarterback can
beat pressure yeah i mean patrick
mahomes couldn't be pressured yeah and i
think when you the most important thing
on any team is a quarterback second most
is you got to protect that quarterback
and the bangles it ended up being a good
pick i thought it was dumb at the time
they picked jamar chase over a couple of
really good offensive linemen really
[ __ ] good and jamar chase is so good
i think it's a good pick but
they have this year and maybe two years
after to spend money and you've got to
[ __ ] invest in an offensive line that
cost them the season and i don't it's
not just everybody's like oh they'll be
back it's you're not so sure yeah
because when you have a young
quarterback like that their salary's
dumb low because of the rookie contract
you're like guaranteed a certain amount
so this is the time you have money to
spend a free agency then when his
contract is up in like two years or
three years you have to spend 50 million
dollars a year or whatever on them and
now all of a sudden your salary cap
space shrinks so you this is your window
these two years
i think left they have to go after it
and you kind of need to try to win your
super bowl now and you got to do it
against patrick mahomes josh allen
justin uh herbert or whatever his name
is like you it's the afc is stacked this
was a this was their chance and i think
they kind of got [ __ ] yeah but aaron
donald should have been super bowl mvp
the only reason he wasn't is they vote
with two minutes left and then the last
drive was all him
it was second and one borough throws an
incompletion third and one should have
got a first down on a handoff aaron
donald [ __ ] stopped around the thing
was joe mixon cold in his tracks
couldn't get the first because aaron
donald just then fourth down
pressure and then the sec to save the
game
yeah it's tricky i i it's hard also not
to give it up to cup though right like
cooper cup is so good and literally if
you look at that last drive it's all cup
it's lit it's all him and when oda he's
done that before yeah it was the last
drive in the conference championship as
well and the last drive against uh bucks
he had the long path dude he's
incredible he's the best receiver in the
league odell stays in line because he
got cooper cubby can't say [ __ ] yeah but
like it was the same thing that donald
did cup did right yeah it's like donald
decided okay it's game time i need to
take over 100 took the [ __ ] over yeah
and cup did that as well in that last on
that last drive and he's done it
multiple times the last drive so i'm not
like angry giving it to cup i didn't
follow the whole season but i have
people talking about oh this is the best
season from a wide receiver ever i don't
know yeah that he got the most
receptions the most receiving yards the
most receiving touchdowns nfl that would
be the best player of the year
it's kind of like julian edelman won
super bowl mvp and yeah
what
he's bringing
to the jewish mvp but cooper cup super
hyper christian he deserved to win too
here you go thank you dove there we go
thank you for forcing julian edelman
for agreeing that the best wide receiver
season ever in history might deserve the
nbc
watching dove suddenly become a rams fan
has been so funny to watch
never talked about the rams all year
then all of a sudden he's buying a big
screen for the studio so we can watch
izzy and the rams what do you give a
[ __ ] about the rams dude you're every la
fan and it's not logically wrong support
a team when they're good it's a good
product but i i want f since he was
emotional about this [ __ ] la gave a [ __ ]
two days ago yeah since he gave a [ __ ]
for 40 years i wish they got it for them
look and shouts to odell beckham jr too
yeah dude he played great he he tours
acl i think that's what people are
saying that's right
but like
he got the touchdown i mean he got 50
yards like
fire cleats you saw those police were
fired 1500 [ __ ] diamonds in them but
like to make sure that you contributed
yeah to that victory it'd be one thing
if he gets injured on the first play and
like doesn't really quote unquote win
the game but without him they don't win
that game
no
i think
it's so tricky because like if he comes
back the next season and they win
another one i think he completely
rewrites history yeah like his whole
story changes whole story changes
finally as a quarterback they can get
him the ball a team and an offense is
smart enough and knows how to utilize
him and all of a sudden he has no ego
there's no issue yeah right it's like he
has no ego being the second wide
receiver but contributing to that team
it's a real shame that he tore the acl
it's really sad i also think if aaron
donald retires there's no way they make
it back oh yeah that was another thing
he said he might retire if they this
might be his last game and then he
wouldn't answer after he was like i just
want to enjoy the win obviously you
should yeah but he's one of the best
defenders in history if he retires i
don't see how you possibly bro you know
what is so cool is um watching the
players get emotional like
if it felt like back in the day with the
bulls with jordan it was like tears
every single time they won they'd given
so much and i saw a few of the lakers
championships and it felt like they
almost like expected to win yes there
was no crying they were kind of like
excited a little bit happy et cetera
dude odell beckham jr was bawling yeah
like holding his
wife's stomach that has their child
inside i presume that's the lauren she
was a wild out girl oh really yeah yeah
[ __ ] okay and the come up yeah
and then um
also aaron donald just like teared up
with his family like it was great to see
the ecstasy that the players were
feeling yeah because you go okay these
people have contributed so much of their
lives and sacrificed so much for this
moment yeah it almost it almost was like
they didn't think was possible
yeah i think it doesn't yeah man like
think about how much you give to comedy
yeah but you don't give your body you
don't give your brain you don't get
[ __ ] trauma in your brain yeah every
single day for this game that you love
yeah they do and the chances of winning
a super bowl are so slim yeah so when
you get it it's got to be the single
greatest feeling outside of maybe
heavyweight champ of the world yeah
because you're just and or ufc you know
heavyweight champ of the world boxing
where you outside of that there's no
thing that requires this yeah
to be the best and the one common thing
you heard from all the players and even
the coaches just like oh we're such a
great team like no no person is just
like elevated this is this person's
winner they all were saying like yo
we're such a good team we play so well
together and that's why we got the win
yeah yeah who's the person on that team
who's like the leader that pulls it all
together the coaches
legitimate actual photographic memory i
think you saw sound clip where you
remember somebody's pulling it up
they asked him about uh games when he
was offensive coordinator like passing
game coordinator of the redskins eight
years ago this game against this team
this quarter uh this much time left and
he knows the exact play
[ __ ] uncanny any one of our wives do
that [ __ ]
i don't know only with things we do
wrong
hey remember that nice thing you bought
for you when yes
so you know odell fulfilled a couple of
drake's bets so yeah yeah drake finally
won like three half a million dollar
bets yeah he lost on one so
it was for rams to win one that
for odell to score touchdown one half a
mil on his boy but then he was like i
think 10 or 15 yards short of like the
yardage kind of was something in the 60s
yeah so you're still talking yeah
yeah million dollars he just uh jesus
yeah yeah
it was one of those things where it's
like
i don't know i i kind of was rooting for
the bangles i was very much rooting for
the bank but i was happy that odell got
away there's a lot of players on the
rams i root for matthew stafford uh he
[ __ ] he played on a dog [ __ ] team his
entire career yeah one season yeah and
he's not the greatest quarterback but
one season with a truly good coach and a
truly good team and he wins the [ __ ]
super bowl yeah and he played his ass
off uh all year and then uh cooper cup
also and odell beckham and aaron
odell beckham and then aaron donald for
some reason i just really wanted them to
get yeah that's great and it was cool to
see them do it man
yeah good super bowl nice to see it be
competitive
[Applause]
you